-Thanks to
newly developed technology,
we here at "Late Night"
now have the ability
to record the tiny voice that is
inside Donald Trump's head.
And you might be
surprised to know
that like everyone's
inner voice,
Donald Trump's is filled with
paralyzing fear and self-doubt.
So here it is, once again,
the tiny voice in the back
of Donald Trump's head.
♪♪♪♪
-Mr. President...
-Hey, Donald.
It's the tiny voice
in the back of your head,
and, oh, yeah, you are
in a minefield right now.
There are so many things
that could go wrong
in this situation.
Who looked
at this guy's outfit and said,
"We should put him in
the same room as Donald J. Trump
and a bunch of reporters?"
This is against every instinct
in your body to stand here,
not grab the microphone,
and point out everything
that is different
about this person.
[ Laughter ]
The hat, the robe, the beard --
Oh, my God.
You want to say something
about the beard.
You're gonna go crazy.
When is this gonna be over?
Somebody get Dark Santa
outta here.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Hey, Donald, it's
the tiny voice in your head,
and, oh, boy,
the tiny table is out.
And you know what
the little table means.
It's time to sign your name.
But don't do it so big
that you run out of paper.
Oh, the big D and the O and the
N and the A and the -- Oh!
You're running out of paper.
I hope you can fit it in --
Oh!
You just made it.
[ Laughter ]
And now show everybody
how proud you are
'cause you signed
a piece of paper.
This is the part
of the job you crush.
You're the best at this.
And now put it away.
Oh, let's do another one.
[ Laughter ]
Let's do another one -- yep.
Pretend like
you care what it says.
Big D...little O, little N,
little A, little L, little D.
Big old T!
Running out of paper.
Don't run out of paper.
There we go.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]